tonight on Brian Ross investigates
inmates and their families in a panic
over a health crisis at this federal
women's prison in Florida
inmates are living in what this lawsuit
calls quote an emergency crisis inmates
telling us that Bureau of Prisons is
covering up a serious outbreak of
Legionnaires disease a potentially
deadly respiratory illness caused by
contaminated water plus the brothers
from Brazil two brothers linked to a
massive corruption scheme and there are
US companies now receiving 100 million
dollars in US taxpayer money meant for
American farmers and ranchers the
Bautista brothers the leading
shareholders have admitted to criminal
acts numerous criminal acts and our
shoutout for the reporter taking on
state officials who he says have been
purging hundreds of thousands of mostly
black and young voters from the eligible
voter rolls sir why do we have to sue
you to get them to get the names of
voters who've been removed from the law
and crime Network studios in New York
City's Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates
good evening and welcome as the world
waits with dread for the latest on that
deadly virus out of China we're going to
focus tonight on another outbreak one
that many say has not received the kind
of urgent attention it needs this is
camp coleman a woman's federal prison in
florida just north of Tampa a place for
an outbreak of Legionnaires disease has
the inmates and their families up in
arms
inmates are living in what this lawsuit
calls quote an emergency crisis this
comes after a Legionnaires disease
outbreak in the facility in January
Legionnaires disease is a severe
respiratory illness caused by inhaling
small particles of contaminated water
the government now admits at least two
confirmed cases and at least 21
suspected cases one of the prisoners
here told me by phone that she and
others are not being well taken care of
I had such a terrible cough that she
gave me some breathing treatments for
two days but I was never seen by a
doctor or had any tests performed on me
I was never called back to see a doctor
others continued to go people were
fighting tooth and nail to go and nobody
was really being seen there their
response to say it lacked would be an
understatement
most people were told purchase
over-the-counter meds on commissary that
I believe was pretty much the standard
of care I had to buy your own minute yes
we had to buy our own medicine that is
correct that is often what happens here
the women were so outraged that one of
them Kara Adams actually filed a class
action lawsuit against the Attorney
General William bar and the head of the
Federal Bureau of Prisons this is my
third camp and by far the health care
here is the worst it is not good
throughout the bureau I would like to
add but there just seems to be a willful
neglect and depraved indifference that
exist specifically at this facility in
response to the lawsuit the government
says all cases both confirmed and
suspect have been and are currently
being treated and that all testing
by the Florida Department of Health
returned negative results for the
Legionella bacteria I think that we all
know that that's not really possible and
they say they've tested almost everybody
and the problem is they can cure that
that's false
they haven't tested like again III if
they have tested 20% of the MA
population that would be shocking to me
we're joined now by Helen pedalin the
daughter was at the cold facility until
being moved last week and by Mark Broder
whose wife Karen is one of the inmates
at the Coleman prison in Florida and
mark let me start with you what's the
latest you hear there from your wife in
the facility well I mean I have to ask
what was just said we're getting very
little information from anyone at the
facility other than our campers we are
being told that people are being tested
or a reading that people are being
tested but the people inside are
obviously not being tested there's more
reports of people doing everything they
can to go to medical to continue to
fight to ask for testing and being
refused and Helen let me ask you how
sick was your daughter she was in f3 so
she wasn't really all that sick but she
couldn't breathe her she had a headache
constant headache every day she had a
she had congestion didn't feel like
getting up and going to work but did
anyway begged for medical to see her
never had so she did not get the
attention she thought she needed no sir
not at all none of them are okay mark a
question for you from our control room
from executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda mark are the women there's men
and women in this facility are the women
not getting the same kind of attention
well the women's camp is a separate
facility from the men's so they're in
their own living quarters and we don't
know what's going on with the
and there's been rumors that people have
tested positive there but there there
are only rumors at this point we have no
way to confirm any of them and mark let
me ask you and Helen as well it's rather
remarkable for the inmates to direct go
to court one of them is suing others are
speaking out publicly do they face
possible retaliation for trying to blow
the whistle on the prison warden and the
officials I feel like they're
retaliating in a little bitty ways you
know just just to being mean to them and
refusing the medical the way they talk
to them and Mark how about you what do
you think it's is it dangerous time for
the these women to be speaking out like
this going public with their complaints
well there's there you know there's
certainly hesitation for people to speak
up the ones that are speaking up are
worried about retaliation you know
there's there's different things I've
heard about people working at the
facility that are trying to feed
information to to the campers and trying
to offer assistance where they can there
seems to be infighting with some of the
medical staff we've been hearing of
where some people are trying to get
medical help and trying to give medical
help and then others would come in and
refuse it and again where we're getting
this all from our loved ones inside and
they are convinced the prison officials
are not telling the whole story of
what's going on there Oh fully I mean
there's there's been little information
that's come out if any at all and and
the information the response that we've
received from the VOP and the response
from the lawsuit that was that was
issued pretty much denied that there was
any issue there at all
and that everyone's been tested and
there's been no Legionella found on the
facility but if there isn't someone has
to explain how all these women are sick
how they all have symptoms that are
similar and and and what they're what
they're doing to solve that problem so
this must be very tense time for you and
for Helen with your loved ones in there
you
the facility and you don't know what's
gonna happen next no but my daughter was
transferred out last week she still
hasn't read Ike she still has congestion
she's supposed to get tested where she
is but everybody in there I'm sure has
it all right and they're not thank Helen
pennilyn mark Broder thank you so much
for joining us keep us posted on though
this will continue to be in touch with
you we asked the Bureau of Prisons to
provide someone to appear on our program
tonight but so far they've declined to
do so the offer is still open up next
the brothers from Brazil
why has 100 million dollars in US
taxpayer money gone to companies owned
by two brothers from Brazil connected to
a serious criminal investigation
next the brothers for Brazil we've been
following the case of two brothers
linked to a huge corruption scandal in
Brazil who have been buying up American
Meatpacking companies which it now turns
out have received some 100 million
dollars in US taxpayer money subsidies
meant for American farmers and ranchers
now members of Congress want to know
what's going on from it's hardly
produced corporate promotional videos
the JPS company appears to be a great
success built on hard work and a
commitment to corporate responsibility
started decades ago by a small-time
butcher in Brazil it has now grown into
a multi-billion dollar worldwide beef
poultry and pork producer the largest in
the world saying it provides the world
with quality food and it has now bought
up some of America's best-known brands
but what the company's videos don't
mention is the scandal-plagued
background big news in Brazil of the two
brothers who run the company judge Lee
and Wasley Batista sons of the founder
connected to a massive bribery scheme in
Brazil that allegedly helped them get
the money to buy up the American company
Brazilian TV showing hidden camera
footage of the brothers supposedly
making backroom deals jbs is currently
under investigation by the Department of
Justice for potential violations of the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act this is
because the Batista brothers the leading
shareholders have admitted to criminal
acts numerous criminal acts consisting
of the bribery of thousands of Brazilian
government officials to obtain illicit
loans from Brazil's national bank the
ill-gotten loans were then used by jbs
to illegally enter and consolidate the
meatpacking industry in the United
States questions about the company came
in to a sharper focus when it was
revealed the company had received tens
of millions of dollars in US taxpayer
money that President Trump said was
meant to help American farmers hit hard
by the trade war with China so we will
ensure that our farmers get the relief
they need and very very quickly
it's a good time to be a farmer we're
going to make sure that jbs has received
little over 100 million dollars in
payments that money I might add was
supposed to have been for struggling
farmers ranchers who have been hurt by
the administration's failed trade
policies in a statement to Brian Ross
investigates the company said it has
quote fully cooperated with all relevant
authorities in a transparent manner
regarding past events unquote and it
says it is an important American
employer providing more than 60,000 jobs
and partnering with more than 11,000
farmers ranchers and poultry producers
but its critics say that doesn't change
the facts of its illicit behavior so
you're saying this is a corrupt company
these are the fruits of a poison tree
really these are the fruits of a poison
tree that's exactly right right and no
one should be able to profit from
ill-gotten gain not in the United States
you may get away with that in Brazil or
in other countries but you should not
get away with that in the United States
farmers and ranchers are being harmed
sumers are being deceived and it's all
been brought about because of the
illegal activity that was conducted in
Brazil joining us now for more on this
is Angela Huffman
she's the executive director of a group
that represents 250,000 individual
farmers and ranchers called the
Organization for competitive markets and
Angela thanks for being with us tonight
tell me is the upset about that you have
about this situation because the
brothers have this background with
corruption in Brazil or because
corporations are getting all this money
well the USDA has promoted this program
to Paris as a bailout for America's
farmers yet a Brazilian corporation and
of those funds it's not fair to our
taxpayers nor our farmers but the fact
is all corporations are eligible for
this money then the company told us they
have to sort of get the money to be part
of the program to provide food and be
part of the market here that's right
but the fact is jbs is a criminal
organization with a
corporate facade and this isn't the food
system that American taxpayers want yet
we're being forced to subsidize it in
the name of farmer bailouts there are
also questions that are being raised in
Congress about the safety record of this
company that's right in 2017 jbs was
involved in bribing brazilian meat
inspectors allowing them to sell an
export rotten meat around the world
including here in the US and how has it
been they've been able to buy up so many
meatpacking big names we know here
mm-hmm
well through these taxpayer bailouts jbs
has profited on the chair trade war with
China they announced back in August that
they were at their best point in the
company's history for global expansion
and they're just gobbling up Meatpacking
companies all around the world so the
trade worth of China has helped them
because they continue to make more
profits and they're getting the
subsidies as well that's right yep while
Chinese ports were shut down to u.s.
products as a result of the trade war
jbs started shipping and products from
its Brazilian facilities and in the
meantime the u.s. funneled a hundred
million dollars into jbs in the name of
US farmer bits the company told us they
think they're being unfairly targeted by
a lobbying campaign connected to a
financial deal that really has nothing
to do with this issue is that something
you know about that's not something we
know about we represent farmers and
ranchers who are really upset about the
results of this program and how do the
farmers ranchers what do they say to you
about this program and how it works well
they're they're struggling you know jbs
admitted back in 2018 to cheating
America's farmers and ranchers by paying
them less than the real value for their
cattle at three separate beef processing
plants we've gotten a lot of calls about
that people are really upset we should
be investigating jbs finding jbs not
giving them taxpayer bailouts
and it appears there are some
investigations now underway according to
the congresswoman there are US
Department of Justice and the Securities
Exchange Commission are investigating
jbs we're disappointed in the USDA and
secretary Purdue just last week
Purdue let congresswoman DeLauro know
that he was declining to investigate and
not putting the bailout money on hold in
the meantime just last week the US
Government Accountability Office
announced its opening a review of the of
the bailout as well so we are making
progress but disappointed in USDA Angela
Huffman thank you so much for joining us
tonight thanks for having me Brian up
next our shoutout the reporter taking on
local officials who he says have been
purging thousands of people from the
voter rolls when we come back
our shout out tonight for a reporter who
has his own investigative fund and has
been working with the Georgia Coalition
for the people's agenda to produce a
powerful lawsuit and some powerful
stories Palace investigation really took
off when he discovered that this elderly
woman christine jordan was turned away
from voting on election day in atlanta
her name purged from the voting rolls in
Georgia
supposedly because she had moved how
long you've been voting miss Jordan was
not just anyone
she's the 92 year old cousin of Martin
Luther King jr. she was thrown with
polling station because they said she
had moved she's been the same house for
over 50 years and she was the host of
Martin Luther King after he would give
his sermons at the Ebenezer Baptist
Church he hasn't moved anywhere but they
threw her out for moving miss Jordans
granddaughter told Palace no one could
explain how her name was taken off the
eligible voter list being able to vote
and no one can give you an explanation
like it's extremely emotional and it
bothers me it bothers me to my core like
there's actually no record of her
whatsoever voting in any election
whatsoever it's ridiculous
panelist discovered what was going on at
the Secretary of State's office in the
Georgia Capitol and elsewhere for six
years I've been hunting down these
secretaries of state the people in
charge of our voter rolls who've been
playing games by removing voters of
color from the voter rolls in Georgia it
was Secretary of State Brian Kemp who
was running for governor of the state
I'm Brian Kim if you want a politically
incorrect conservative that's me I
demanded that he give me all the
information
the people had been removing from the
voter rolls the names addresses
he said hundreds of thousands of people
almost half a million had moved out of
Georgia in two years and then he
confronted him about what was going on
why do we have to sue you to get them to
get the names of voters who've been
removed so I when he stonewalled me on
his list of people he removed I did
something that it's rarely done I
actually filed a federal lawsuit under
the National Voter Registration Act
which said you have to hand over your
files because it's about manipulating
the voter rolls a judge ordered Brian
Kemp to turn open up his files on the
voter seeds removed how he removes all
backed by the Palas investigative fund
we have an expert team that that it was
that's pretty hard to match anywhere
it's very expensive very difficult what
I've been able to accomplish with this
lawsuit is not only opening up the files
of these officials who are secretly
playing games of the voter rolls I'm
opening up for every investigative
reporter and reporting team I've gotten
calls from many many papers and many
outlets for this information voter fraud
is all too common President Trump made
much of alleged voter fraud in this
country people voting twice when he
appointed the Secretary of State from
Kansas Kris Kobach to head up a special
investigative Commission which has yet
to turn up any evidence of widespread
voting fraud we want to make America
great again we have to protect the
integrity of the vote and our voters
when Trump said that there's massive
vote rigging I think he's right
but it's the cronies behind him who've
been the center of the vote rigging and
palaces that Kansas Secretary of State
is one of the culprits sending other
states cross-check lists of common names
alleging they have registered twice mr.
Kovic
hey hey I want to congratulate you you
are the number-one fraudulent voter
hunter in the United States you're the
guy behind the cross-check list the
title on this list is duplicate voters
okay so wait I've don't you know most of
the names you have said that there are
it's a massive problem with double
voters you've given out this list
pleaser and this is daughters this is
the list you say it's potential double
voters fella says he hopes all the
reporters in the US will pick up now on
what he has been doing it's not my job
to elect or stop a theft of election or
do anything you know that's not my job
my job is to expose this material this
is part of a national program to remove
voters of color before the 2020 election
now this isn't about Democrats or
Republicans it's about right and wrong
it's about whether we're gonna use a
kind of new Jim Crow trickery to remove
voters of color and young people from
voter rolls well I got to tell you that
being an investigative reporter is a lot
better than working for a living that's
our program for tonight thanks for
joining us we'll see you back here next
week